nous sommes en pleine coupe du monde
donc de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent
pour demander voir venir avec mes gros
sabots une égalité salariale entre les
hommes avoue valérie regarder cela ne
saute pas franchement aux yeux mais
c'est bien une demi finale à roland
garros
les deux joueurs s'affrontent sur le
court simone mathieu 5000 places à
moitié garni quelques instants plus tard
rafael nadal et rodger federer ont droit
au prestigieux court central pour leur
demi-finale le sport féminin est il
condamné à rester au second plan dans
certaines disciplines les disparités
sont importantes
en football si les françaises sont
sacrées championnes du monde elle se
partageraient trois millions et demi
d'euros de primes
c'était 32 millions pour les garçons
étaient dernier les droits télévisés la
billetterie et les partenaires
publicitaires rapporte beaucoup plus au
football masculin
la norvégienne à daegu berg élu meilleur
footballeur du monde a décidé de
boycotter le mondial pour notamment
dénoncer le manque d'équité salariale
la parité des gains c'est en revanche le
cas depuis 2007 à roland garros alors
roland garros bravo pareil et des gains
alors dans le foot en revanche j'ai les
chiffres du beauvaisis riant ses 96 % de
moins 96 % de moins que ces messieurs
est ce que vous vous dites c'est normal
elle rapporte moins d'argent elles sont
encore moins connus et sait où vous
dites non il faut égalité salariale
comme par exemple au tennis je ne peux
absolument pas plaider pour l'égalité
salariale
je suis désolé donc par ces raisons le
football ce n'est pas que du sport c'est
un business c'est du divertissement et
aujourd'hui les femmes qui s'affairent
dudit aujourd'hui regardez les 10
millions de téléspectateurs devant
devant le premier match c'est le
l'exemple à ne pas sortir
exemple qui tient à ne pas sortir
pourquoi parce qu'en effet le foot
féminin ça démarre depuis peu c'est un
business qui en pleine éclosion en effet
et ça va monter peut-être beaucoup plus
vite que le foot masculin qui a lui
s'entend donc forcément il ya des
différences aujourd'hui en 2019 delta
est normal parce que pour laver elle
sait pas encore c'est logique que ça
choque mais dans l'autre sens c'est une
logique aussi économiques
quant à day gerber qu'on a vu à l'écran
elle a trois cent mille abonnés sur un
style un sdf de ces jolies voilà la
meilleure joueuse de le ballon d'or la
meilleure joueuse du foot au monde a
joué à lyon parfait mais quand on
regarde le meilleur joueur de foot
hommes messi ronaldo qui voulait la
religion c'est pas mon problème c'est
120 millions 130 millions d'abonnés on
n'est pas dans le même ratio du tout
donc il ya une logique économique
d'aller y ait des zones arides ça n'a
rien à voir venir au fur et à mesure et
à suez est atteint on voit s'écouler
cette coupe du monde ça leur fait du
bien c'est top 10 millions de
téléspectateurs
c'est ça leur fait du bien ça business
du foot féminin il faut correctement
parce que là franchement c'est fini ça
fait que vous avez ouvert la voie et
qu'on a vraiment l'honneur de
s'engouffrer dans une petite brèche que
vous nous avez laissé merci steam aurait
dû profiter justement profiter du
business qui s'est mis en place des
stades qui sont fabuleux remplissez les
l'équipe de france mais bien sûr mais
c'est un business l'équipe de france
féminine france norvège mercredi soir à
nice s'était pas plaint jusqu'à
avant-hier parce que la france a fait un
match fabuleux d'ouverture ça y est les
gens s'y pressent et tant mieux et j'en
suis ravie je suis le premier à suivre
et à me mettre en bleu blanc rouge pour
autant le business il n'est pas encore
là et quand elles généreront autant de
ce que génèrent les gars moi autant elle
est déjà un peu plus malheureux je me
remets sentence qui est celui des
thibault j'ai envie de trappes et mais
j'entends rapidement très rapidement
c'est vrai qu'il ya un calcul
mathématique on va pas bien sûr il va
s'agir maintenant il faudrait qu'à une
logique a nommé rail à une logique
économique
mais il ya aussi un état d'esprit hyper
misogyne hyper machiste dans le foot
qu'il n'ya pas par exemple dans le
tennis et ils viennent d'en faire là ils
viennent d'en faire excuse-moi des sonos
la finale dames à roland garros mais
jamais par exemple aligner les tarifs
c'était quand même les premiers à le
faire on est loin du compte dans le foot
donc il faut simplement que dans le
discours
on redescend d'un petit peu et toi le
premier mon chat même si je t'adore est
ce que tu me donne vraiment l'impression
qu'on est quand même un peu des mondes
coupe du monde ben peut faire bouger les
lignes
est ce que ça va changer un peu la donne
et centre est complètement d'exploser en
est
les jeunes footballeuses ou se mettre de
plus en plus au foot c'est en pleine
éclosion comme je le disais et c'est
génial de voir d'ailleurs tous les
français qu'ils s'unissent derrière
l'équipe alors que en effet bien il ya
encore quinze jours peu de gens
connaissaient les noms je tiens les
paris je vous dis que en septembre il y
aura dans les écoles de foot va beaucoup
de petites filles parce qu'elles auront
vu un mondial qui vont venir s'inscrire
et ce sera formidable
il en fait c'est les marques qui ont été
moqués de fans je suis fille si wallace
et des marques qui ont clairement été
stupide qui n'ont pas vu la manne qui
n'ont pas vu qu'il pouvait faire plein
d'argent et on l'a bien vu vendredi 10
millions de téléspectateurs ça fait bien
longtemps que les bleus n'ont pas fait
ça passe à fait au point qu'ils ont fait
5 millions voilà ils ont fait un mois
que c'est moi du coup tf1 a revu ses
tarifs à la hausse vers qu'à l'origine
les matchs de définir pour les matches
des filles à l'origine la pub était à 67
1300 euros vendredi
là elle sera quasiment eau douce et 113
1300 euros sur sa géniale on voit
comment fait on fait avoir de l'argent
je demande pas l'égalité tout de suite
mais 96 % de différence
c'est quand même scandaleux voilà c'est
pas normal est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'aux états unis
non mais ce qu'il faut remarquer quand
même c'est que c'était autrement plus
élégant le match assez minin que le
match masculin comme le tennis est un
sport élégant là elles ont montré un
foot élégant excuse moi mais les
roulades de neymar les coups de boule
des joueurs c'est cette directive ça
c'est subjectif neymar fait des choses
aussi extraordinaire et surtout ils
génèrent de l'argent dans le monde
entier que ne génère pas encore les
femmes ça normal quand quatre jours il
gagne le salaire mais della serra je
veux parler des salaires des
footballeurs en effet ils sont
incroyables il ya une différence d
immoral et renvoie ça et je suis pas
responsable du fait que les fournisseurs
ainsi que l'égalité mon vieux c'est le
principe de l'égalité les casques et
comme tu vente le football masculin
était en train de vanter la force
masculine contre à la délicatesse
féminine là c'est le principe de
légalité tout le défend pas et mes
fautes notamment l'égalité sur le
terrain c'est de voir si les mêmes
règles c'est le même sport après sur ce
qu'il génère dans le monde entier je
suis désolé je suis c'est pas moi qui
remplit les stades ce aussi le public
sait qu'à une réalité économique en gros
que l'équipe de france notamment d
les bleus sommes pour l'instant plus
d'argent que l'équipe de blessés c'est
bien marrant c'est bien marrant d'être
des massages
c'est la loi du sport c'est l'argent
alors c'est uniquement l'argent la loi
dieu malheureusement pierre de coubertin
quand il a inventé le sport c'est
participe à ce débat pierre de caubel
sait plus si vous êtes fameux moins
payées que les hommes au football est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est normal
ou bien pas normal pas normal bien
évidemment sur la 500 d'entre vous
évidemment sur un plan moral
oui évidemment pas normal mais pour 24%
d'entre vous c'est normal parce que
j'imagine qu'ils se rallient à la à
l'explication de t-bone